certain things happen in life especially
I feel like in my life and my journey
that just feel meant to be and this is
one of those it's amazing when Stefani
is just a girl who loves performing as
much as she loves giving back the
superstar singer is spending a lot more
time in Las Vegas these days with her
residency show at Planet Hollywood
so she teamed up with the cure for the
Kids Foundation
Nevada's only non-profit childhood
cancer treatment center it's just an
amazing opportunity for children that
are sick fish I mean they shouldn't have
to deal with this when got so involved
the organization named a patient exam
room after her ET cameras captured the
exciting celebration what does this mean
to you to have her here today and have
her support oh it's amazing I mean to
have something like when Stefani support
our organization and bring awareness to
what we do here is remarkable we're just
so grateful I'm just gonna cut in and
say there's one star in the room and
it's right here
when is definitely a big part of the
Vegas world
she says she couldn't be more grateful
this whole opportunity to be here in
Vegas I mean the community has been so
warm and so welcoming to me I was
shocked you know to be able to get on
stage and and and you know tell my story
and have that exchange of love that I've
had all these years and have my life
boils down to a stage show and then just
you know $1 for every ticket that his
soul goes to this charity so it's just
an amazing you know I don't know place
to be in my life that I should just take
a check and go wow like and thank you
[Music]